the Joe Rogan experience the real way to
get someone into Jesus is to lead by
Jesus's example and be a really good
Christian someone says well why are you
such a nice person
say because I'm a Christian and a real
Christian is a really nice person the
person be like damn I want to be a
really nice person and say well once you
come to church with me on Sunday and
they say you know you get the church
wasn't really in that's how you do it
you can't be Jesus on the corner of
Hollywood Boulevard and LaBrea but then
when they corner you you got that's
gonna be cut up like I seemed demonic to
me man
he creep me the [ __ ] out that creeped me
out man that guy's used to telling
people things like that seems to yeah
the people point his finger out long
fingernail you'd make a great demon not
imagine what it must be like to be a fly
on the wall one of those billion dollar
preachers just they must be getting
[ __ ] they must be oh it has to be right
of course has to be top-shelf they have
it flying them in from Czechoslovakia
and [ __ ] just got the crew of a skiing
in on a [ __ ] Hill of cocaine it's
crazy how yeah they got a bunch of
actors and plants and all that [ __ ] but
it's crazy how they get people to
believe it and they get put in trances
and [ __ ] and you know some of them of
our acting but some of them are like you
know there's a certain percentage of
people that are hypnotizable what is it
you know and maybe it's the people that
didn't get sucked into pro wrestling pro
wrestling could have got him they
wouldn't believe that that was real they
missed that and they got they got sucked
into like the snake handlers do you
think because when you go to that you
know that's those hypnotist shows the
scam is that before the show like this
considered the scam part before the show
they go into the audience and they find
people that are easily hypnotized right
so they bring them out of things they do
is they let you be aware that they might
call upon you and so
to make sure that your story matches we
would like to know what whatever
happened to you is there something
that's bothering you so that we know
that when Cindy the Magnificent when she
calls out to you that your story matches
up with the piece of paper this little
weird tricks they do it yeah they asked
them to fill out these forms yeah talk
about their childhood
that's the psychic that's I kick [ __ ]
for sure like listen people talk but I'm
talking about what preachers do this
hypnotist shows yeah they take like a
couple maybe they take one problem and
they hypnotize them then they wake them
up they make them do weird [ __ ] that
they don't remember oh yeah dude I saw
that before yeah I've seen it so that's
real oh it's real so there are people
percentage of the population who knows
what it is maybe it's 10% maybe it's 60%
who knows but there are people that can
be put under a spell on under a spell in
it they could be in a trance yes do
something while they're awake they're
awake and they do something under
command with without any control and
they don't remember it and then they get
snapped out of it
yes oh that's real yes that's creates of
varying degrees but in its real in live
audiences which is particularly weird
yeah Frank Santos the R rated hypnotist
was a staple in Boston when I was coming
up and I was an open mic or Frank
actually even ran a comedy club at one
point in time and it's not his son is a
hypnotist now Frank Santos he would do
stitches comedy club
me and Greg Fitzsimmons and Nick DiPaolo
and all these guys we saw him do this
and he would do it on a regular basis it
happened every week he had one night a
week wait and it wasn't just that Club
and was one night II witty we get
stitches but it was like one night a
week at Nick's comedy stop and one night
a week at giggles sorry but he would get
a bunch of people out of the audience
and he would have a bunch of volunteers
who wants a volunteer to get the people
on the stage and everybody will I can't
believe we're here
and they would hypnotize me and hit
batons been hypnotized him and do this
thing you're getting sleepy gonna listen
to me I'm gonna count to five and when I
count to five you were gonna be doing
push-ups and underneath you is gonna be
Madonna and she's gonna be naked and he
would do it and it would work on some
people look at people he was you're not
under come on come with me and he would
get rid of them but
some people just be under and you'd be
like this isn't real is this real but
then you would see your friend go up
there you would see someone you knew go
up there and you would see people see
their friends go up there and what they
couldn't believe it and the person was
really doing it and you could tell
they're really doing it and they'd be so
embarrassed
they'd be so embarrassed when they found
out that they did this and for these
people they're like what yeah you came
in your pants and like some guys would
actually come in their pants they would
come in their pants he would tell them
I'm gonna count to three and I like
number three you're gonna come in your
pants
one two three you gotta be like oh he'd
seem get like super embarrassing these
aren't good actors well you could see
the embarrassment in their face they
were bewildered they were so confused
and like what happened how did this
happen but it wasn't everybody the one
if things probably couldn't I wonder if
there's a I would love to see a
documentary on people getting hypnotized
and like proving the trio and doing
different well I got hypnotized
I got hypnotized yeah yeah but I didn't
get hypnotized to do anything
I got hypnotized by Vinnie Sherman
Vinnie Sherman the mental coach did he
make you do things you didn't remember
oh no I just laid there I he gave it to
me no I laid there and he talked to me
while I was laying there and when he was
talking to me I knew he was there
and I knew I was there and I knew I was
just chilling on this couch it wasn't
like I was in a trance and I was going
somewhere and I was very aware that it
was happening but it was like he was put
me he was put me in a suggestive state
and he was talking to me about various
things that I wanted to work on mostly
organization and discipline stuff like
discipline like getting things done and
it was just one something that I'm
always concentrating on and then when it
was over it was just over I was awake
through all of it but it was weird
it was like a weird state it was like as
if like the regular world has like a
crazy filter over it like leestown
that's a yes it's hard to guess I would
probably say yes and it sounds like you
were you weren't hypnotized like that
kind of like those dudes that don't
remember what not you know that but he
doesn't do that though and I think other
people can do that and I think they do
that to some
people but that's not what he's trying
to do anybody his died I think and I'm
speaking for Vinny but I think that
anybody can allow themselves to get into
this suggestive state to get in this
state of hypnosis but that's different
than the kind of people that will think
that they really are having sex with
Madonna
on stage yeah they could tell people
that really do come in their pants
that's great those people locked in
there's something locked in about them
but it was a hundred percent real you
think those people the cane are easily
hypnotizable can be influenced but they
could be hypnotized by something on a TV
screen
may evening is possible yeah mate maybe
why not
I don't know what that element what is
what's causing you to go under you know
I'm saying like is it just the words
yeah what is saying it is it them
looking you're Frank Santos was an
interesting guy he's a very short fellow
and this is coming from a short guy and
he had glasses and he was kind of like a
big guy and he was heavy you know he's
overweight and it just seemed real
unassuming and sweet and kind and soft
and just hello everybody how are you how
are you you know and he just was just
talking to you are you gonna get sleepy
gonna get sleepy get a sleep you're
sleepy and they were just not off maybe
like whoa what the [ __ ] he just knew how
to do it and he would do it so calmly
and confidently and he would do it every
week and every week we would watch some
people who'd work on some people who
wouldn't work on I wonder if anybody can
do it anybody can put someone under
trance if they were taught the right way
and they maybe you got to do is learn
something or is it some kind of special
gift or some I bet it's a skill I bet
it's a skill but I bet it's just like
having a good personality like some
people you want to hear them talk all
the time dude what if there's dudes like
that the guy they date and they're just
looking for girls they could hit ya
they're just looking for girls that get
hypnotized so they go they gotta live
when they take him home make him do all
sorts of crazy [ __ ] I knew a guy who was
a comic who also worked as a hypnotist
and he could hypnotize people and I
remember walking by him while he's
talking that's girl and she goes no I
don't want to be hypnotized
and I remember thinking what are you
saying her oh this is back in the dizzy
- what if there was a hypnotist slash
comedian that mastered hypnotizing
people from the stage and you got him to
laugh hysterically at everything so he
just like killing and crushing every
night well I think comedy is a form of
mass hypnosis it's funny you say that
because I think that's what's happening
when you're locked in like when you're
locked in and everyone's locked into
what you're doing in and you're killing
there's these moments where it's like
the audience sinks minds with you like
hypnotism it's very similar because when
you're killing there's this feeling that
you get where you're like it's an energy
feeling it's not just you saying
something and they think you're so funny
so you feel so good it's like you're
riding this wave and as long as you
practice the material so much that you
know where the beats are and as long as
you're so engaged in the material that
you really are thinking about it as
you're saying it you're not bullshitting
them you're not just saying the words
because they know what you're just
saying the words they want you to be
fully engaged but there's these moments
when you are fully engaged and they know
you are and you you're riding this wave
together because you know the material
so much so that you could be fully
engaged but not have to think about what
comes next because you know it comes
next but you're saying is if you've
never said it before and you're thinking
of it as if you've never thought it
before you're thinking of it as if you
never said it before and they're locked
in and it's like hypnosis it's very very
similar as far as I know I mean I've
never hypnotized anybody but I feel like
when you're killing it's a state of mind
is like you're you're you're achieving a
group state of mind with all these
people it's weird